if you get covet 19 and you recover from
it does that mean you're immune to the
virus and even if you were to become
immune how long would that immunity last
now we're still waiting on studies to
really give us definitive answers to
these questions but in the meantime I
think what can help us understand coded
19 immunity is thinking about our body's
responses to other infections and I kind
of think of it as an immunity spectrum
so what I want to do now is talk us
through some examples along that
immunity spectrum to help us better
understand where kovat 19 might fit in
[Music]
on one end of this spectrum is
varicella-zoster virus the virus that
causes chickenpox and you might remember
from your own childhood that if you get
chickenpox once you usually develop the
lifelong immunity to it and you don't
get it again this kind of lifelong
immunity happens because of antibodies
something you've probably been hearing
loads about recently antibodies are
proteins made by our immune system that
protect us from harmful things
those can be infections like viruses and
bacteria but also toxins and cancer
cells with chickenpox your body turns
out antibodies that are in it for the
long haul and it also has cells are
ready to make more antibodies should you
meet the virus again you can get exposed
to viruses through natural infection or
this is a preferable way you get
immunized meaning you get a vaccine that
introduces your body to a weakened
version or a dead version of a virus so
that your body knows what to recognize
and it mounts a solid immune response
that stops you getting sick and if you
didn't get sick with chickenpox as a kid
you get two shots of the vaccine that
gives you long term immunity now some
people who have a weakened immune system
can get chickenpox a second time and in
fact our bodies are never able to get
rid of the virus totally it stays latent
inside our nerve cells and in around
one-third of people the virus
reactivates later in life and causes
shingles so how does covert 19 compare
to this example
obviously the ideal situation would be
that you get Co bed 19 once and that's
it your immune forever to the virus that
causes the disease
unfortunately this doesn't seem that
likely and here's why there are early
studies showing that when people recover
from Co vid 19 they do have antibodies
in their system but because this is such
a new infection one we're not sure how
long those antibodies hang around for
and two there are some reports of those
antibody levels dropping really low just
a few weeks after infection here's
another example whooping cough this is
caused by a bacteria and usually if you
get infected once that immunity lasts
from four to twenty years for quite a
big range because the immunity fades
over time the CDC recommends you get
vaccinated against whooping cough but
even with that you need to get booster
shots those are shots that you get after
your initial vaccinations to make sure
you stay protected over a period of time
so even if we do develop a successful
vaccine for co vid 19 maybe that
vaccination scenario will be similar to
whooping cough where you get your
initial doses of vaccine but then you
have to get booster shots as well so
here's our next example h1n1 influenza
also known as swine flu studies have
shown that immunity to h1n1 can last
anywhere from 2 years to 10 years this
is a strain of flu that caused a
pandemic in 2009 but now circulates
pretty regularly alongside other common
flu strains and with the flu the reason
that we're getting new flu shots every
single flu season is because flu strains
are changing and so literally every
summer in the northern hemisphere
scientists are racing to predict which
flu strains are going to hit us and what
kind of vaccine they need to make for
that specific flu season some experts
predict that Tsarskoe v2 will follow
that same path as h1n1 meaning it causes
a terrible pandemic at first but then
circulates much more like a regular
virus after the fact
[Music]
now when it comes to figuring out where
the new coronavirus might fit on the
immunity spectrum I think our best bet
might be to compare it to the original
SARS coronavirus saw stands for severe
acute respiratory syndrome and that's
caused by the corona virus that emerged
in 2002 and caused a pandemic in 2003
infecting more than 8,000 people around
the world studies of SARS patients who
recovered showed their antibody levels
peaked around two to four months and
that they offered protection for two to
three years so is this a timeline that
we might consider for SARS Kobe - well
there are some studies that show that
when our bodies are infected with SARS
Kobe - we produce what we call in
neutralizing antibodies and these can
stick around and offer protection for a
couple of weeks that's what the early
studies are showing but clearly a couple
of weeks is a ways off from two to three
years I think the glimmer of hope might
be that there's so much genetic
similarity between Tsarskoe v2 and SARS
kobe-wan another good comparison we have
right now is to the four corona viruses
that cause the cold immunity to these
seasonal corona viruses starts fading
just after a few months and within a
year most people are vulnerable to re
infection meaning it won't go away
whilst or infect people but it won't
cause such serious disease and it won't
cause so many infections so that's a
possible scenario that we might see with
the new corona virus so on the other end
of the immunity spectrum compared to
where we started is HIV people with HIV
do develop antibodies to the virus but
either those antibodies don't stick
around for long or the virus has really
cunning ways to hide from the antibodies
that's partly because HIV is constantly
mutating every time it's replicating
inside the body that makes the virus a
moving target for our immune system some
good news on the koban 19 front is that
this corona virus does not seem to
mutate anywhere near as frequently as
HIV mutates that means it stays a much
more consistent and
means we have far less of a moving
target and because of that some experts
are saying that reinfection with the new
corona virus could be less likely just
because the virus isn't changing so much
so our immune systems recognize it and
know how to fight it but I still think
it's way too early to be saying that
reinfection is unlikely just because of
how new this virus is and how much we're
learning day to day so we don't know
exactly where covert nineteen is gonna
fit along this immunity spectrum but
let's say you get infected with the
virus and it does give you antibodies
that hang around for months maybe even a
year or so in that scenario you can
start thinking about herd immunity as
one way out of the pandemic herd
immunity is when a significant
proportion of a population has become
immune to a disease either through
becoming infected or being vaccinated
and when herd immunity is achieved it
stops a disease spreading like wildfire
through a population that exact
proportion of people that need to be
immune to a disease in order to achieve
herd immunity it varies from pathogen to
pathogen and it depends on how
infectious a microbe is we're still a
ways off from thinking about herd
immunity as our way out of the coded 19
pandemic for at least two reasons the
first being that we just don't know yet
how long those antibodies will hang
around for and how protective they'll be
but second because for herd immunity for
kovat 19 you'd need between 50% to 70%
of a population to become immune and we
don't have a vaccine year meaning we'd
have to see a lot of people just get
sick from the virus and that's not a
feasible way out of the pandemic and
finally there's that question about
antibody testing I think if we get
studies that show us how protective
antibodies are to this virus and how
long those antibodies stick around then
in that case widespread antibody testing
could be really useful especially if
it's a quick finger prick blood test to
help us understand who's immune for whom
is it safe to go back to work and how
quickly could we start resuming normal
activities but even if a large number of
people have been infected recovered and
have
munity it's still not going to trigger a
sudden reopening of society there's
gonna have to be a gradual peeling back
of containment measures like sheltering
in place to make sure that we're
constantly guarding against a second
wave and against future outbreaks and
that's gonna be our reality until we
have a vaccine thanks so much for
watching
drop your questions here in the comments
below or reach out to me on social media
[Music]